abone ol
o o
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
abone ol
o o
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
abone ol
Evet sevgili İlke soluklan duysan seni
olabilir miyiz sahneye Hoşgeldin tekrar
teşekkür ederim Şimdi Ali abinin bana
sordu sorayım ben de sana sorayım Nasıl
bir his bir dansçı için bir balerin için
boş koltuklara dans etmek tüm koltuklar
dolu
bu gibi hayal ederek dans ettim başka
türlü yapamaz başka türlü çok zor Peki
beni bulmuşken bir şey daha soracağım
Benim izlediğim fındıkkıran dan biraz
daha farklı bir versiyonu Sen burada
bize sergiledin Evet bu bizim klasik
bale il dışında neo-klasik tarzda
dediğimizi Vale yorum oldu Türk
bölgemizin en önemli koreograf larından
Uğur seyreğin fındıkkıran balesinde ön
kısa bir bölüm sığındım sizlere Uğur
seyrek Ayrıca çok Özeldir benim için
buradan kendisine de sevgilerimizi
gönderelim O zaman teşekkür şimdi ya
Bütün bu güzellikleri bize yaşattığın
için ilki Öncelikle kime teşekkür
etmemiz lazım ya Seni kim ittirdi bu
baleye ya Annem beş yaşında tanıştım
baleyle sonra sekiz yaşına geldiğinde
ilkokula devam ederken Konservatuarı
yarı zamanlı ya çalışmalarında devam
etmiş oldu
Ben 11 yaşına geldiğimde de kazanmış
olduğu İtalyan Lisesi ve konservatuvarı
bale bölümü arasında bir seçim yapmam
gerektiğini söyledi anneciğim Tabii ki
böyle dedim çok emindim ve konservatuvar
sınavını kazandım üç aşamadan oluşuyor
Konservatuarı bale sınavı fiziksel
özelliklerinize bakılıyor müzik
kulağımıza bakılıyor yaratıcılığı gücü
yaratıcılık yüzünüze bakılıyor ve
sonrasında bir mülakat alıyorsunuz
burada devlet sanatçımız mevsime bana
dedi ki ilk işim dedi biliyor musun Bu
mesleğin ne kadar zor olduğunu dedi Evet
öğretmenim biliyorum dedim ama nasıl
bilebilirdim ki o bir yaşında bu kadar
zor olabileceğini Bu mesleğin Çünkü
sabah 9'da başlayan Vali dersleri
kafadasın sıkı bir topuzla girilen
kültür dersleri üzerine akşamüstü
saatlerce sonra tartar çalışmaları
derken eve gidip o sımsıkı topuzu
açısındaki rahatlama Duygu
bu yoktu gerçekten 10 sene sürüyor
konservatuar eğitimi bu süreçte sabrın
ve disiplinin ne demek olduğunu elimden
gelenin en iyisini Nasıl yapmam
gerektiğini ve bedenimin ruhumu zihnimin
aynı anda bir bütün olarak nasıl
çalışması gerektiğini öğrenmeye çalıştım
gerçekten kolay değildi a 14 yaşında
katıldığım İlk uluslararası bale
yarışması Lozan daydı sonra sampetersbuk
ve Japonya'daki yarışmalara katılarak
Ülkemizi temsil ettim bu deneyimler
kendime olan güvenimi ve gelişimi mi çok
iyi yönde etkiledi
bu işte böyle Peki şunu merak ediyorum
mezun olduktan sonra konservatuardan ilk
işi ne oldu ya da ip performansın mezun
olduktan sonra İstanbul Devlet Opera
balesi'nin çok merak ediyordum şöyle bir
bakayım dedim katıldım İstanbul Devlet
Opera balesine ikinci senemde başrollere
yazılmaya başladım şöyle bizdede tüm
diğer dallarda olduğu gibi her aşık bir
sistem var sıramın gelmesini beklemeniz
gerekiyor ve sabırla çalışarak Sıramı
bekledim bu sırada grup çalışmaları
sonuç çalışmaları derken bir yandan da
başrol çalışmaları başlamıştı hayalini
kurduğum tüm rolleri dans ettim Çok
şanslıyım ki bu Şansı kendim Yarattım
ama ailem annem karşıma çıkan eğitmenler
birbirinden kıymetli koreograflar
gerçekten kutu şansım yanımdaydı bunun
için minnettarım Hayata
com
bu sonra pandali dönemi geldi çattı
dönemi Evet ben şimdi iki tabi Takip
ettiğim için Instagram'dan ilk aklıma
gelen soru oldu yani sonuçta hayatı
sahnede olan bir insan ne yapabilir dans
etmediği zaman diye sonra ikiye bir
şeyler yapmaya başladı biraz Biz oralara
anlatıyoruz şöyle Bizim rutin
çalışmalarımız var ve saatlerce süren
programlarımızda önce mutlaka en az bir
buçuk saat böyle dersi yapıyoruz bu bar
Valide şu anlatacağım bar çalışmaları
orta zıplama hareketleri dövüş
hareketleri gibi pek çok hareketi
kapsayan bir buçuk saatlik bir form
tutma çalışması ve sonra saatlerce süren
provalara gidiyoruz şimdi evde
kaldığımız zaman yani duramazdım bedenim
durursa eğer uzun süre Çünkü
biliyorsunuz bedenlerimiz yapmaya çok
müsait Hadi bugün yatayım Hadi bugün
yatayım derken derken bir daha tekrardan
kaldırmak çok zor oluyor
bu ile artık 20'li yaşlar 30'lu yaşlar
gibi bir yaşa gelince tekrardan
toparlamak gerçekten çok daha zor bunun
için dedim ki hemen bir şey yapmam lazım
zaten o sırada evin şekli değişti
kendime 3 metrekarelik bir alan Yarattım
boş bir duvar buldum ve ve Tamam dedim
ya o zaman canlı bale dersleri
paylaşırsam biliyorsunuz Kendi kendinize
motivasyon sağlamak Her Dalda olduğu
gibi çok zor kendi kendine motive edip
çalışmak her gün çalışmanız gerekiyorsa
o zaman bir canlı yeni koy kimin geldiği
önemli değil yani hani koyunu orada Sen
çalış Çalışmak zorunda kalacaksın Çünkü
onun o yüzden derken 3 bir ilgiyle
karşılandı çalışmalar içinde Vale yapma
aşkı olanlar Profesyoneller amatörler
gençler Çocuklar derken ben de kendimi
daha da geliştirmeye başladım bu süreçte
tabi arkaya var bylabel dediğimiz bir
var ve
bu salonun ortasında bir bale muşambası
yapmış oldum ve bu şekilde devam ederken
a ortak çalışmalar paylaştım
arkadaşlarımla Yurtdışında yaşayan yurt
içinde yaşayan farklı şehirlerde orta
kelimelerle Canlı yayınlarda buluşarak
pek çok ders paylaşmış olduk ve bunun
yanında yoga pilates gibi farklı
metotlarında olduğu çalışmalarla
paylaştık ben orayı da soracaktım Çünkü
beni böyle seni seyrederken bir baktık
yakıyorum yoga hocası çıkıyor Say çiğ
bir şey al atıyorum hani Bale ve bunlar
ne alaka Evet evet çok alaka Çünkü
Bizler bir tek böyle yapmıyoruz pek çok
farklı disiplin birbirinden besleniyor
ve birbirini destekliyor bu her zaman
için tüm diğer dağlarda olduğu gibi çok
çok önemli Onun için işin Üstadı
isimlerle de buluşarak tek çok çalışma
gerçekleştirdim çok çok zevkliydi aynı
zamanda dünya dans gününde ülkemizde var
olan tüm diğer Üstat öğretmenlerin ve
direktörlerle
bir bir buçuk saat içinde sanıyorum 15
farklı kişiyle buluşarak farklı
konuşmalar ve ve kutlamalar yaptık İki
farklı klasik Balenin önemli sorusunu
falan paylaştım o sırada yani ne
yapılabilecek Sem onu yapmaya ve kendimi
motive etmeye ve arkadaşlarıma evde
kaldığımı süreçte gerçekten beraber
birbirimizi desteklemek ve güçlenmek
için çalışmalardan Bıkmadan usanmadan
çalıştım Sonuç olarak 122 günde 80 bir
tane ders paylaşmışım bunların hepsini
bir günlük tutar gibi YouTube kanalına
yükledim kendime de hatıra olarak güzel
çalışmalar oldu Çok zevkliydi müthiş
bence çok mu hiçbir şey yaptığım için
şöyle bir şey var Eğer bırakırsak Yani
hem düşünsen hem fiziksel olarak
bıraktığımız anda orada gidiyoruz Çünkü
çok kolay o olumsuzluk bir de bunu da
kaybolma ki Oraya girmeye izin vermedim
bu onun için mutluyum yani Bizim de
böyle bir seçim yapmış oldum diğer de
Çünkü ben şimdi hayal ettim Mesela bir
tane küçük bir bana öğrencisini hayal
edin İlke kodalı hayrana 2q daldan ders
alma şansı yok şimdi bir anda oldu
mesela günler boyunca açıp onu takip
eden minik bal öğrencilerinde olduğunu
ben biliyorum ben kendi adıma çok
teşekkür etmek istiyorum İlke sana neden
teşekkür etmek istiyorum bildiğin ve
yaptığın işle sahnede olamadığın bir
dönemde elini taşın altına koyduğun için
bildiklerinle birilerine fayda sağlamaya
çalıştığın için sana gönülden teşekkür
ediyorum Son sözlerin için sahneyi sana
bırakıyorum Çok teşekkür ediyorum ve bu
süreçte şöyle bir şey fark ettim sanata
sanatçıya olan ilgi ve merakı
canlandırmak için aslında içimizdeki
sanatçıyı tekrardan uyandır mamız
gerekiyor Bunu da düşündüren bu süreçte
aldığım birbirinden güzel m
Ne oldu yani dimdik çabaladık çalıştık
ünv anlarımız oldu Fakat bunların
gerçekten hiç bir önemi yok Çünkü biz
sadece bir ünvan değiliz biz bir
ünvandan çok daha fazlası yız bunun için
tekrardan çocukluğumuzu hatırla Sak
özgürce oyunları oynadığımız ne oyunlar
oynardık nasıl hikayeler yazardık bir
baskı korku kısıtlama olmadan içgüdüsel
olarak bak hayal gücümüzü kullanarak
Çünkü o çocuk hala bizim içimizde Ve o
çocuk bizi bekliyor çünkü her çocuk
aslında sanatçı doğar ve biz bazen bu
kargaşanın içinde o çocuğu unutuyoruz
Eğer onu tekrardan Bulabilirsek sanatçı
kişiliğimizi de tekrardan bulmuş oluruz
Çünkü o çocuk Sensin o sanatçı senin
için de teşekkürler
abone ol